e aí galera que aceite meu canal todo
bom vocês eu estou ótimo eu queria muito
agradecer teresina piauí
por isso aqui muito obrigado pra mim foi
um sonho e apresentar um lugar que eu
sempre quis apresentar um sonho
realizado neste final de semana agora 26
e 27 eu sou todo de goiânia goiânia
quatro sessões esgotadas e até aí mas
ainda está vendendo ingressos para a
quinta sessão e é só você que é de
goiânia clicar o primeiro link na
descrição do vídeo é pago pra igreja e
passando e se na semana nos próximos
dois finais de semana eu sou todinho
sabe quem eu sou todinho na bahia ana e
elsinho e salvar roupas pra comprar seu
ingresso também no primeiro link a
descrição do vídeo com o instagram este
agradecer percela bem marcando meu doce
de leite e iogurte leite e nem a pessoa
nem peço que todos pensamos na foto eu
estava eu acho que desde quando eu
comecei a mexer na internet o instagram
fta grão estava estragando que têm
impacto no instagram não é instagram em
está doente está a dar que falar o que é
muito bom é muito bom que era posta foto
eu posso várias fotos de momentos ótimos
da minha vida nessa foto boas chamou de
um ódio 888 de gente que tem um estádio
privado estaria privada que tem um
cadinho assim eu tô lá e prá posta foto
minha sexy domínio de bola e wils
comentar a lixo merda seu bosta -
inscrita num filme africano rik esquece
dos fãs lindo adorei a foto olha a foto
do perfil da pessoa danã milan e levou
porque as cotas tudo nessa pessoa
naquela clínica no instagram privado não
dá um desgosto
aí você tem namorada ou namorado aí você
pára e pensa meu deus do céu
figo ou não consigo
ok vou seguir a minha namorada é o
seguinte eu sigo 600 pessoas no
instagram samsung mais uma pessoa lá é
não importa quem eu tenha seguida chega
pra mim e isso me dizia que quem é adote
um cachorro arroba hotmail.com tu tá me
traindo com o cachorro ainda se isso
gera abrir então quando eu sigo uma
pessoa privada só pra ver quem é a
pessoa eu tô sacrificando eu tô
aguentando briga aí eu espero a pessoa
aceitar é que o estádio é privado cara
clique em seguir wagner aceitar a
solicitação passe ea espere passou a
semana e do semana três semana um mês a
pessoa do meu deus do céu que se resume
essa pessoa humilde a pessoa aceita
macho meu deus do céu quando a pessoa
sai do minha solicitação eu me
surpreendi eu me surpreendi porque o pé
porque eu sabia de tudo eu já estudei
nessa vida eu achava que eu sabia de
tudo nesse mundo agora que satanás tinha
instagram a menina era feia feia mas tu
tá ligado como um pai só o
espermatozóide mais pai aqui tem de
beber mas que ela foi brincar com o
relógio do ben 10 aí quebrou e ela ficou
só no monstro desses agora eu entendi
por que é que este instagram tcheca
geada porque se abrir se abre as portas
do inferno uma semana depois a retirou
está grampeado privado eu comentei na
foto tranca de novo pelo amor de deus
agora me dá ódio e jorge vamos sair hoje
vamos jogar uma bola e jorge não dá cá é
porque puxa eu toco para tudo bem as
pessoas só ocupa esse é normal uma hora
depois
o instagram instalar o jorge o time da
bola com a galera um monte de amigo que
não é eu vou ver na foto foi que ele
marcou marcou menino que chamou ele no
instagram do menino privado nem por
jorge jorge casa quer casa e que descai
melhor em casa com o melhor está
garantiu jorge é pelo bem dele para
tirar o instagram do primário puderam
até ficar uns filho doido fico puto
quando o cara olha a foto de perfil da
pessoa é linda é tom é fecho é pró
paroxítona é perfeita você segue a
pessoa que você segue a pessoa precisa
nem aceito você olha a foto você fica
pensando meu deus como foi o acidente
que essa pessoa levou depois que ela
tirou essa foto de perfil porque na foto
de perfil a pessoa perfeita o instagram
privado é ruim principalmente para quem
gosta de estar o que é estranho que
alguém se explica a gente acha que sim
que tal que é quando você pega do pavê a
história da pessoa tenha que está o que
sabe à a acordar sua bostas e fuça força
força theo mas em fundo tal do porrete
vai tão fundo marshall que acha petróleo
está o que há na hora que conta é
bloqueado e quebra a perder a fé não
quero que você comece aqui embaixo que
você mais odeia no instagram eu também
está grama estabeleça que está
aparecendo na tela pra vocês e vai
conseguir lavar nunca perdi minhas fotos
sensuais que eu possa viajar muito pelo
brasil fazendo show então por várias
coisas fora do lugar diferente eu vou é
isso aí muito obrigado você assistir
esse vídeo até aquilo que aqui embaixo e
gostei se você tiver gostar desse vídeo
no facebook apostar de vídeo 90 takut lá
você me ajuda demais e marca um amigo
seu que usa muito instagram os
comentários no facebook valeu é nóis
beijam